remercie d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france alors après la fuite dans la
presse de ces enregistrements whatsapp
de policiers la mobilisation aujourd'hui
devrait-elle encore être plus
impressionnante que celle en début de
semaine on l'a vu un mardi dernier près
de vingt mille personnes ont défilé à
l'appel du collectif adama traoré
oui bonjour oui il est clair que il y
aura probablement des des rassemblements
en région parisienne mais aussi dans un
certain nombre de grandes villes qui
peuvent être importants aujourd'hui dans
les jours à venir parce que c'est un
sujet qui est à vif
vous avez à la fois une partie de la
population qui a le sentiment que face à
des comportements violents ou à des
propos très violent discriminant ben y'a
pas de réaction du pouvoir
en tout cas il n'y a pas de de
reconnaissance du pouvoir qu'il ya un
problème dans la boue lice sur ces
sujets de discrimination de ou de
racisme et puis il faut pas oublier que
c'est ces manifestations notamment la
manifestation parisienne qui a
effectivement très bien fonctionné avec
plus de 20000 personnes
elles sont aussi alimenté par une colère
sociale donc vous avez à la fois la
conjonction d'un sentiment de d'impunité
et d'une colère face aux forces de
police dans un contexte de colère
sociale d'après crise du sanitaire du
coc vide ou parce que vous avez beaucoup
de jeunes issus des quartiers populaires
qui sont dans des situations très
difficiles ou qui ont des familles qui
sont dans des situations très difficiles
perte d'emploi perte de ressources
et donc la colère sociale plus le
sentiment d'injustice alimentent ces
manifestations les manifestations qui
vont donc s'élancer cet après midi c'est
pour dénoncer les violences policières
la discrimination mais aussi le racisme
qui sont des phénomènes assez différent
mais est ce qu'il y ait un lien entre
ces mouvements
il ya en tout cas en france depuis très
longtemps notamment dans les quartiers
populaires
un sentiment encore une fois deux ou un
certain nombre d'actes sont commis
ça va des des contrôles de police au
faciès ça va ça touche aussi évidemment
des actes de brutalité policière
cette actualité elle est aussi alimentée
par des révélations que nous avons à
chaque jour 1 sur ce problème dans la
police et encore une fois la seule
manière de lui dire est de répondre à
ces manifestants et d'éviter une sorte
de contagion sociale de ces
mobilisations c'est que le gouvernement
doit selon moore avoir un discours très
clair et sans ambiguïté reconnaître
d'abord que le problème existe parce que
quand on écoute le ministre de
l'intérieur on a l'impression finalement
que ce ne sont qu il n'y aurait que
quelques comportements anormaux du côté
de la police mais qui aurait pas de
problème global or nous pensons qu'il ya
un problème global et qui ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui qui date
j'irai de depuis plusieurs dizaines
d'années
donc il faut absolument que le
gouvernement reconnaisse le problème et
prennent des décisions alors ses
décisions ça passe d'abord par le fait
que les procédures des procédures
doivent être engagées à chaque fois
qu'il ya des comportements de violence
ou des propos racistes ou discriminants
et ans et encore une fois la population
a l'impression qu'à une forme d'impunité
police face à ces comportements donc il
faut casser ce sentiment d'impunité
et puis il faut aussi réfléchir à des
mesures pour faire en sorte que par
exemple dès qu'il ya un comportement de
la police sur un contrôle ou sur un acte
malveillant à l'égard de la population
et puisse y avoir une sorte de
traçabilité et que les citoyens qui
seraient victimes de ses agissements
finalement puissent faire valoir leurs
droits devant l'administration mais
aussi devant la justice et donc il faut
réfléchir à tout ça et il mais il faut
pas que le gouvernement continuait à
faire l'autruche en considérant que que
tout ça n'existe pas ou que tout ça se
ré inventé par je ne sais qui et s'ils
continuent à être dans le déni
ces manifestations vont gonfler merci
beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
florent guéguen je rappelle que vous
êtes directeur directeur de général de
la fédération des acteurs de la
solidarité